[Música]
era un Secreto a voces y ya no hay
espacio para la especulación el ex
presidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump anunció que será aspirante a la
nominación del partido republicano Para
volver a llegar a la Casa Blanca en
Washington un anuncio que tiene lugar
dos años antes de los comicios lo que
augura que esta Va a ser una larga
disputa por la validación de su partido
el republicano para llegar precisamente
a la casa presidencial Trump hizo este
anuncio desde su casa en maralago que
está ubicada en el sur del Estado de la
Florida después de haber generado
muchísima expectativa a través de las
redes sociales escuchemos
para hacer que Estados Unidos sea grande
y glorioso de nuevo esta noche anunció
mi candidatura a la presidencia de
Estados Unidos
en lugar de poner a Estados Unidos en
último lugar como ha hecho la
administración biden muy abiertamente y
con valentía porque no me imagino
diciendo pongamos a Estados Unidos en
último lugar creo que hace falta valor
volveremos a poner a Estados Unidos en
primer lugar
pero tal y como prometió en 2016 soy su
voz Yo soy su voz el establishment de
Washington quiere silenciarnos pero no
se lo permitiremos
si bien este anuncio era esperado muchos
se cuestionan si era el momento acertado
para hacerlo la coyuntura es muy
complicada tiene varias causas legales e
investigaciones en su contra también el
partido republicano no tuvo ese
desempeño arrasador que esperaban en las
elecciones del medio término y al
interior del mismo partido hay
discrepancias frente a la figura
política que representa a Donald Trump
De hecho no es el único que tiene
intenciones para participar en esta
nominación incluso podrían hacerle
contrapeso al interior del partido
estamos hablando del recientemente
reelecto gobernador del estado de la
Florida Ronda de santis que está
fortalecido después de las elecciones de
medio término también el ex
vicepresidente Mike pence que no ha
dudado en hacer fuertes declaraciones
contra Donald Trump y su gestión en la
casa blanca y también suena entre los
comentarios de los pasillos el
gobernador del estado de Virginia glenn
pero la lista es mucho más larga en
cuanto a los nombres que suenan para
participar en esa lección primaria al
interior de los republicanos estamos
hablando de Nicky Jam Cruz Larry hogan
Chris Christie entre otros nombres que
aclaró suenan Existen los rumores pero
todavía no hay confirmaciones para que
participen en las primarias por eso hoy
en el debate de France 24 nos
preguntamos ganará Trump la nominación
Qué necesidad tiene el ex presidente de
volver a llegar a la casa blanca una
cuestión de orgullo o una cuestión de
necesidad para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a John polga jessimo él es
analista político y profesor de la
academia naval de los Estados Unidos
también está con nosotros Iván Sapiens
él es analista político y socio de hogan
lowells ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden participar en este debate
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
ustedes ya las conocen estamos en
Twitter en Facebook También estamos en
Instagram
se encuentran como arroba el debate
guión bajo
f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta personal
la etiqueta para que dejen sus
comentarios numeral el debate f24 todo
junto todo pegada no olviden también que
en nuestros contenidos también están
disponibles en diferentes plataformas de
podcast estamos en Apple podcast en
Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces saludando a John
dándole la bienvenida al programa y
preguntándole John estará una
candidatura esperada por muchos muchos
especulaba ya sobre sobre este posible
anuncio pero cuáles son sus impresiones
después de haber visto este anuncio del
ex presidente Trump
bueno primero buenas tardes
Es un placer estar con ustedes hoy por
supuesto tiene tiene una posibilidad la
candidatura de Trump el sistema
electoral estadounidense del colegio
electoral va a dar posibilidades a casi
cualquier candidato de los dos partidos
grandes
cualquier otra cosa que se piense sobre
su intento de regreso la candidatura de
Trump no puede ser descartada como una
broma
inverosímil como como su anuncio del año
2015 no es un expresidente que cuenta
con una fuerte lealtad de un núcleo
Sólido y y devoto de votantes
conservadores que para eso están listos
para seguirlo donde quiera que los lleve
Incluso si es Derrotado Sí además el
Trump de de 2022 tiene muchos más
herramientas a su disposición
para anunciar su calentura y para
desempeñar una una campaña Claro en 2015
veíamos a un hombre de negocios
reconocido en el país que intentaba
llegar a la presidencia ahora estamos
viendo Es a un expresidente que está
tratando de volver a la casa blanca son
dos personajes de la escena política
completamente diferentes ya hay una
experiencia de por medio iban los saludo
también le doy la bienvenida al programa
y la misma pregunta como Punto de
partida sus impresiones generales sobre
este anuncio de la expresidente Trump
como lo toma usted
Bueno para mí Yo creo que es un es una
oportunidad para levantar un Trump para
pues bajar un poco la temperatura que
está en los Estados Unidos declaración
por la cual los republicanos pues no
fueron tan fuertes como ellos esperaban
era de Donald Trump Entonces el partido
por sí en los últimos días ya le estaba
echando la culpa de lo que pasó y además
de eso
tuvo unas elecciones fenomenales
entonces rápidamente grandes se
convirtió en la figura más importante
del partido político republicano había
encuestas dentro de dos días que
señalaban que también ganaban mucho
entonces Donald Trump no tenían O sea no
tenía otra más que declararse el
presidente de los Estados Unidos Además
de eso apenas candidato para el
presidente es para pues para meterse a
esta conversación eso yo creo que ellos
hicieron la teoría que si él está
corriendo para presidente que el
departamento de Justicia Federal pues
deje no va a tomar acción legal lo cual
no tiene ningún sentido legal pero yo
creo que
ha pensado de manera política
eso me lleva a preguntarle a plantearle
la pregunta que hacía al final de la
introducción del programa qué tanto
tiene esta aspiración de Donald Trump va
a ser candidato de los republicanos de
ego de haber perdido o de no haber
repetido la presidencia
haber tenido una reelección inmediata al
final de su primer periodo presidencial
o una necesidad política de tener que
repetir precisamente para huir de la
justicia
Bueno yo creo que si yo creo que en
parte sí yo creo que pues sí de de
definitivamente de la mente de verdad
mucho de sus seguidores no no más no
perdió pero que tiene que regresar para
enseñar que en realidad no perdió
Entonces yo creo que esos eso es un
punto de higo pero yo creo más
importante es que el partido republicano
en realidad se está moviendo fuera
de las esfuerzos de Donald Trump se
están y hay mucha gente que está
diciendo que para ganar el 2024 pues que
tienen que hacerlo
para luchar por su posición Claro ese es
un punto que vamos a analizar más
adelante aquí en el programa Quiero
preguntarle ahora a John por el contexto
en el que llega este anuncio de esta
aspiración para las primarias dentro de
los republicanos hay un escenario muy
que uno puede pensar que de pronto es
adverso para para el ex presidente
además que no hubo buenos resultados en
las primarias para los republicanos como
ellos esperaban todavía está por
definirse el voto en el estado de
Georgia
hay muchísima controversia política en
el país era el momento para lanzar esta
candidatura muchos especulan que lo
tenía que hacer ahora antes de que otros
se lanzaran
La pregunta es era el momento para
Donald Trump o era el momento para el
partido republicano porque son las
preguntas distintas Sí para Trump
definitivamente fue fue el momento
adecuado
tras
realmente unas pérdidas legislativas o
falta de ganancias legislativas
significativas para el partido
republicano y y la victoria contundente
del gobernador Hernán decentes en
Florida Trump quería mantenerse en las
noticias y y dentro del escenario de la
política republicana ahora es lo mejor
para el partido republicano lo lo dudo
sinceramente en este momento Sí el
partido quiere ser más o menos tiene dos
alas y una de las alas la ala que que
ganó bastante en las elecciones es la
ala trompista pero sin Trump no O sea el
trompismo sin Donald Trump como en
Brasil el bosnarismo ganó sin bolsona en
las elecciones del 30 de octubre
creo que eso es el debate que vamos a
ver dentro del partido republicano y
también en la política nacional de ahora
al 2024 Iván su opinión era el momento
para presentar esta aspiración esta
candidatura o era simplemente un
mecanismo para digamos espantar a los
demás republicanos que tal vez estaban
pensando en en aspirar a esa nominación
y dejarle el camino a Trump bueno
claramente no era el momento oportuno el
partido republicano una de las cosas que
sabemos ya es que dentro de las
elecciones todos los candidatos al menos
ganaron uno dos pero todos los
candidatos que Donald Trump impulso en
estas elecciones perdieron y muchas de
la razón de las que perdieron es que
porque espantaron a los independientes y
los moderados políticamente Entonces el
partido en realidad se quiere mover
fuera de la zona de Trump lo más rápido
posible pero O sea hay unas elecciones
en un mes en en Georgia Entonces si todo
es un candidato republicano en Georgia
de ninguna manera tienes que el
presidente Trump en las noticias
recordemos que los últimos elecciones
perdieron dos elecciones en Georgia
porque estamos Trump se metió dentro de
selecciones la única la única razón por
lo cual los demócratas tienen el senados
porque se metió en Georgia y otra vez se
está metiendo la otra antes de las
elecciones claro Hay que entender que
este anuncio tiene lugar dos años antes
de esos comicios presidenciales Todavía
falta medio medio mandato presidencial
del presidente biden pero aquí comienzan
a a por lo menos a construirse las bases
de cómo va a ser esa carrera
presidencial cómo va a ser ese escenario
político de Estados Unidos en las
elecciones pasadas veíamos que el
protagonista principal de los comicios
era la polarización entre la sociedad
estadounidense están empezando entonces
a construir
el escenario político para los próximos
dos años como lo vio usted Iván
Bueno yo creo que
muchos de los republicanos están
hablando de que una de las lecciones una
de las cosas que aprendieron dentro de
estos comicios es que los independientes
y los moderados los espantaron entonces
que en realidad hay que cambiar el tono
lo republicanos para poder para que
ellos puedan regresar a Pues algo a un
contexto donde pueden ganar las
elecciones en dos años yo creo que van a
tratar mucha gente va a tratar de bajar
un poco la temperatura dentro de la
política en Estados Unidos Yo creo que
es la única manera en la cual los
republicanos tienen una oportunidad de
ganar y hacer
ganar más asiento dentro de la cámara de
representantes Pero va a ser un reto muy
fuerte porque las fuerzas de las fuerzas
de Trump y la gente que que pues que
piensa que uno tiene que ser muy
agresivo en la política que son son
muchos pero no son la mayoría para ganar
las elecciones y que es la hacer
política de Donald Trump insultando un
poco a su oponente acusándolo incluso
diciendo algunas imprecisiones en sus
discursos como lo hizo justamente en el
en el discurso del anuncio de su
aspiración presidencial
Johnson sus impresiones Iván toca un
punto interesante y es bajarle un poco
el tono a la agresividad política que ha
vivido Estados Unidos en los últimos
años puede ser un factor importante para
para esa candidatura en los próximos dos
años Cuál es el suyo
claro creo que tampoco hay que
subestimar el papel de la percepción de
la erupción democrática sí los dotantes
de los estados de Michigan wisconsan Y
otros
rechazaron a los candidatos republicanos
que arrojaron dudas sobre los resultados
electorales de 2020 los estadounidenses
quieren callados más moderados Sí hemos
visto también polarización dentro del
partido demócrata en los últimos años Sí
con una Hola una ala progresista y una
ala más moderada Y con estas elecciones
hemos visto
probablemente un retorno al centro para
el votante mediano estadounidense sí no
quiere a rechazado el extremismo de
varios de Los candidatos de Trump y
también en algunos casos rechazaron el
extremismo del otro lado vamos a ver si
compro
posible bajar el tono y la agresividad
en la carrera o la campaña para el 2024
si es decentes puede ser diferente si es
Trump va a haber exactamente como fue en
el 2020 Y cómo fue en el 2016 va a estar
muy interesante ver lo que sucede en
estos dos años Cómo se construye ese
panorama político y si de verdad se
logra bajar un poco ese tono de de
agresividad política y en Estados Unidos
vamos a ver eso en qué termina yo no
usted habla de una percepción de algunos
de los votantes de Trump de no querer
irse a los extremos ya se la jugaron por
el extremo en elecciones anteriores
quieren de pronto moverse un poco más
hacia el centro moderarse un poco
Quienes son Entonces los votantes que
siguen a Trump en este momento en la
instancia que está el país y en la
instancia en la que está Donald Trump en
este momento quienes lo siguen quienes
lo pueden apoyar en esas aspiración y
posible candidatura
definitivamente tiene dos bases
distintas por lo menos dos bases
distintas hay que comenzar con el apoyo
que goza de los evangélicos blancos de
los Estados Unidos también algo que
comparte con con Brasil y bolso este
grupo representa alrededor del 14 15% de
la población a los Estados Unidos sin
embargo es el grupo religioso más grande
entre los votantes republicanos y ha
sido una base muy fuerte para Donald
Trump en el 2015 16 y luego en el 2020
sí segundo no hay que descartar el
votante
desafectado el votante O mejor dicho el
ciudadano que no vota no el llamado
independiente que no votaba o el
Demócrito que no votaba o el republicano
que no votaba que de repente se sentía
representado por el el rechazo que
expresaba Donald Trump sí que finalmente
alguien le dio voz Entonces ese grupo
también
le sigue Como si fuese su profeta y con
estos dos grupos tiene suficiente base
para lanzar su candidatura y son bases
John ya le doy la palabra Iván son bases
que se mantienen sólidas a pesar de
estas investigaciones que hay en contra
del ex mandatario y todos estos casos
legales que hay que le han hecho mal la
prensa a la imagen de Trump
definitivamente porque a pesar de las
acusaciones de corrupción de del 6 de
enero y y y otras cosas
él ellos sientan que él les representa y
la representación es lo más importante
que puede existir en la política
buscando un candidato Sí claro Iván y le
preguntó por un componente importante de
esa base de votantes que puede tener no
solamente Trump sino que también son
bases importantes de los republicanos en
general y es el voto latino sobre todo
el voto del exilio cubano que está en la
Florida que normalmente en su mayoría
vota republicano Trump puede contar
todavía con estas bases para sus
votantes para de Cara a una posible
elección
Sí yo creo que una de las cosas que pues
se vio unas elecciones de
hacer varias semanas es que pues ya
básicamente en Florida es un estado rojo
y muchas dos razones por las cuales es
un estado republicano ya casi de base es
que porque los cubanos los venezolanos
los colombianos que están en el sur de
Florida Pues ya básicamente
ya los demócratas no compiten O sea
vienen de vienen muchos de ellos vienen
de países por razones y políticas
subiendo al socialismo y pues damos y
fue muy efectivo en decir mira no todos
demócratas son socialistas y ya eso eh
yo creo que sí va a seguir con ese con
esa base Pero los que también vimos es
que en otras partes del país los los
latinos en Arizona Nevada en California
en Nuevo México todos los números parece
que ser que básicamente igual que
nosotros reacciones Entonces el cambio
del voto latino básicamente en el sur de
Texas y en Florida Pero todo es el punto
de que se está que está cambiando a
nivel nacional es bastante exagerado
basado en lo que pasó en estas
elecciones hablemos Iván del panorama de
quienes pueden entrar a competir en esa
nominación republicana yo presentaba
algunas de las caras de pronto más
destacadas mencionaba el gobernador de
Florida ronda santis también Alex
vicepresidente Mike pence y al
gobernador del estado de Virginia Como
vi usted a estas estos tres posibles
candidatos sobre todo a mí me llama la
atención
de santis que ha tomado muchísima fuerza
entre los estadounidenses después de su
triunfo en Florida y también las
declaraciones que ha hecho Mike pence en
los últimos días que qué análisis puede
hacer usted
Yo creo que One decentes es
el el carril que está corriendo van
decentes es básicamente yo soy como
Donald Trump yo soy igual de agresivo
que Donald Trump pero yo no tengo todos
los problemas de hecho soy más joven
entonces por eso yo creo que lo vea él
como el reto más grande que tiene que Eh
pues que tiene que dominar porque
básicamente están en el mismo carril si
ves a al gobernador de Virginia O si ves
yo creo que los carriles que ellos están
corriendo son un poco más moderado
Aunque
bueno estuvo en la presidencia de Down
Champions
Pues él él él se está considerado como
el más moderado y cuando yo digo más
moderado por cierto yo no digo de manera
política sino que básicamente le están
bajando el tono de cómo están hablando y
el problema para el partido republicano
es que pues la última vez que funcionó
la
en el 2016 o sea perdimos elecciones a
un 2017 perdieron muy feo en el
2018 normalmente los presidentes de los
Estados Unidos se realizan perdieron muy
mal también el 2020 y ahora en el 2022
corriendo mucha gente con la misma pues
fórmula mágica de Donald Trump Pues otra
vez normalmente en un año cuando estás
es un poder pierdes muchos asientos y
estos histórico no ha pasado en 50 años
entonces para el partido republicano
tienen que resolver este hecho de Cómo
sacar a Donald Trump y yo creo que te
sientes es el reto más grande para él ya
vamos a analizar de cómo está el tema de
de la percepción del partido republicano
y al interior del partido quiero seguir
hablando de estos posibles contrincantes
John su perspectiva su opinión sobre
estos tres posibles candidatos todavía
no hay nada oficial que puedan ser
importantes a la a la nominación
republicana pero son esas caras que
suenan fuertemente en los pasillos y
entre los analistas allí en Estados
Unidos
como definitivamente el rival más fuerte
de Trump tal cual como dijo Iván porque
tiene todo el trompismo sin las
debilidades de Trump sí
los otros candidatos tienen también
debilidades no en el caso de de My pence
quien está ligado fuertemente a Trump
con todo lo que eso implica pero no
tiene Su carisma y tú no tiene el
momento personalista que
Detrás de él sí es un mayor debilidad y
en el caso de
Glam young que ha ganado impulso desde
que ganó la este la gobernación de su
estado
él está intentando ser el candidato más
tradicional del partido republicano
hasta ahora lo ha hecho pero lo hizo en
Virginia aprovechando de la coyuntura
política no con
con quejas de los republicanos es un
nuevo contexto político en el país en
este momento dado la decisión de dabs
versus Jackson Respecto a los derechos
reproductivos el aborto y eso debilita a
un candidato como clanyonkin a nivel
nacional
usted dice John que de santis es el
rival a vencer lo vencer a Trump o de
santis va a vencer a Trump usted vea de
santis como candidato en la para la
presidencia
yo voy a santis como el candidato pero
también yo veía a cualquier otro es algo
Trump en el 2015 Entonces
no deberían tomar mi palabra cada vez
que alguien apuesta en contra de Trump
él ha ganado salvo en el 2015 Iván
teniendo claro este escenario con estos
candidatos que puede tener de santis que
le quite esa nominación a Trump Más allá
de los problemas legales y las
investigaciones que tiene ahora de
santis que es una cara más joven que
está digamos en Boom en efervescencia en
este momento en Estados Unidos que le
pueda quitar esa nominación a trompa
Bueno yo creo que básicamente lo que
tiene decentes además de lo que
mencionas es que no tienen los problemas
legales Yo creo que es muy posible casi
probable de que antes de antes de que
hayamos lleguemos al verano que entra
que estamos Trump va a tener problemas
legales Entonces se le va a hacer un
poco difícil
entonces por varias razones y vamos a
empezar por la razón razón financiera
ahora que Donald Trump está corriendo
para el presidente y el partido
republicano no puede no puede pagar los
los abogados de Donald Trump hay muchas
prohibiciones ahora que no existían
entonces y se le puede convertir en una
situación bastante cara legal para
defenderse de los casos que vienen el
caso que puede venir del departamento de
Justicia también es bastante grave que
puede venir en su contra y que se va a
tener que defender Entonces yo creo que
ese carril de
los problemas se pueden convertir peor
antes del próximo verano iban continuó
con usted mencionaba Yo hace algunos
minutos en el programa que veíamos a
Donald Trump muy distinto a lo que era
Donald Trump en el 2015 en ese Entonces
teníamos a un hombre de negocios muy
conocido en el país que intentaba llegar
a la presidencia ahora vemos a un ex
presidente después de cuatro años de
haber estado en la casa blanca tratando
de regresar justamente allí a la Casa
Blanca en Washington cuál cree usted que
son esas cartas que pueda jugar Trump a
lo largo de estos dos años para esa
candidatura Cuáles son esas fichas que
él puede jugar que
destaque de estos cuatro años que tuvo
de presidencia y que puedan ser sus
armas para enfrentarse tanto a la
candidatura interna en las primarias
como una posible candidatura
presidencial
Sí yo creo que ahí es el punto más
interesante y el resto más grande para
para el partido republicano porque yo
creo que los seguidores de Donald Trump
son seguidores
del partido republicano hay que recordar
que en el 2015 cuando te damos corrió
para presidente era demócrata y cuando
corrió para para presidente corrió en
contra en contra de todos los
republicanos y el partido republicano
por por decir o sea era demócrata le
ganó al partido republicano y los
seguidores de Donald Trump son
seguidores entonces tiene una fuerza
política que después a la mejor no puede
ganar sino más hay dos o tres candidatos
Pero si son cinco o seis o sea que tiene
que llegar al 36 38% o 31% para hacer el
candidato lo puede ser muy fácilmente
porque los seguidores de Donald y es es
muy claro siempre las encuestas que no a
otros están siguiendo Donald Trump y
John Cuál es su perspectiva Cuáles son
esas fortalezas de Trump para estos dos
años que viene de campaña
es una personalidad de reality TV
tiene herramientas para para mantenerse
en las noticias y ser parte de la
conversación diaria de los Estados
Unidos no la supervivencia de Trump
representa la dificultad con los
movimientos y electorados para descartar
los presentes populistas no siempre
vuelven sí no no desaparecen los
populistas en cualquier país del mundo
fujimori perón Rafael Correa cualquiera
ellos siempre quieren volver y vuelven
casi sin excepción y en el caso de Trump
tiene sus seguidores es un político muy
personalista Más allá de ser populista y
va a movilizar esa base
a raíz de Su carisma yo no veo Su
carisma a ver pero pero Su carisma sí Su
carisma o su facilidad para para
conectarse con las masas puede ser
Carismático este caso puede entrar
también a discusión debate Pero sí tiene
la facilidad de conectarse con el
público y enviarle un mensaje certero
sea verdadero no pero logra entregar ese
mensaje porque también dice muchas
imprecisiones en sus comentarios como lo
dijo el día de su anuncio que había
dicho que había terminado el muro en la
frontera con México cosa que no es
cierta para este bloque final John Iván
quiero que hablemos del partido
republicano como tal vemos que hay
divisiones ya ustedes lo han comentado a
lo largo del programa hay dos variantes
claramente marcadas Acá hay dos
perspectivas muy distintas de lo que el
partido quiere proyectarle hacia los
votantes qué imagen está mandando el
partido republicano habiendo tenido
no habiendo tenido esa ola roja que se
esperaba en las en las elecciones de
medio término y teniendo dos ideales
completamente diferentes de partido una
cosa es la mirada de Trump y otra cosa
es la mirada que tienen los otros
candidatos comienzo con Iván
Sí yo creo que
el O sea la cosa que les cuesta lo más a
los republicanos en el y le costó los
mamás en esas elecciones y le va a
seguir con cosas no
es que es una marca de Donald Trump en
el partido republicano es es lo que
decimos nosotros en inglés la gran
mentira o sea Donald tramposo dentro de
todos los periódicos sigue diciendo que
él no perdió las elecciones que las
elecciones las ganó que él no perdió las
elecciones y que pues quedaron por
razones de que gente hizo trampa y yo
otros problemas electorales y ese punto
de de después atacando a las de las
democracia y yo creo que es el punto que
más puntos le ha bajado a los
republicanos conocen boca con los
independientes y los moderados mucha
gente vio todo todo lo que hizo el
congreso para
de investigaciones acerca de lo que pasó
el 6 de enero cuando la gente entró al
Capitolio y muchas veces estaba diciendo
que estaban Pues que estaban perdiendo
tiempo los demócratas y los republicanos
que participaron pero pero no fue uno de
los razones número uno por los cuales eh
los republicanos se dieron y siempre y
cuando nos hacen eso van a tener
problemas hacia adelante
John para entender estas divisiones que
hay dentro del partido republicano Esta
división marca una ausencia de Liderazgo
que tal vez Entonces Donald Trump entra
a ser como este gran líder del partido
Bueno de hecho ya es el líder del
partido pero pero hay crisis de
Liderazgo hay crisis de de Unión de
ideas de hay crisis de
fundamentos básicos al interior del
partido republicano o eso se mantiene
sólido
creo que hay demasiados
políticas que quieren ser líderes dentro
del partido republicano en este momento
comenzando con el senado que acaba de
ganar en The bigs
el que es más radical como
líder del partido minoritario en el
senado y también quiero Me parece que
tiene ambiciones propias que le acaba de
ganar a break Scott también más
extremista como presidente de la cámara
de representantes o como decimos en
inglés
los líderes del partido republicano
tienen un dilema quieren repudiar a
Trump sin repudiar a varios elementos
del trompismo Sí porque ellos
aumentaron el camino a Trump no a su
elección y a su éxito entonces quién
repudiar a Trump pero sin sufrir
consecuencias y lo podemos ver después
del 6 de enero que que muchos
republicanos
emitieron declaraciones en contra de
Trump y en contra de los
insurreccionistas Y después volvieron a
aceptar él como presidente entonces
tienen creo que dificultades son tan
definir Cuál va a ser su camino
definitivamente entre las dos a las
principales Y qué punto puede ser ese
punto unión entre las dos salas Johnny
eso es la buena pregunta para algunos
Glam yonken representa ese punto de
encuentro entre el tipo como
o incluso
republicanos más de los años no 90
principios de los 2000 y el tropismo no
en temas sociales de las llamadas Las
Guerras de de de cultura
Bueno pues vamos llegando al bloque
final de el programa quiero que hagamos
las conclusiones John y van sobre lo que
puede venir para esta aspiración
presidencial de El ex presidente Donald
Trump que aspira a través de una tercera
candidatura llegar a un segundo mandato
no consecutivo allí en Estados Unidos
comienzo entonces con Iván para las
conclusiones que se viene ahora para
Estados Unidos para estos dos años de
campaña una intensa visibilidad de Trump
en los medios de comunicación o como lo
de usted sí yo creo que tiene
eso es
es un talento político único y
básicamente el domina todo lo que son
las noticias yo creo que aunque le
quitaron el suelo no funcionó sigue
dominando y yo creo que está mucho más
va a ser una fuerza enorme dentro de las
primarias republicanas yo creo sí
también sí tendría que pasar yo puesto
que iba a ganar pero veremos cómo le va
en la situación legal yo creo que la
situación legal le también puede tocar a
sus hijos y a su hija entonces
a lo mejor eso le quita un poquito de
fuerza pero también quiero también yo
creo que los republicanos van a tener
que buscar Cómo ganar elecciones en el
2024 el condado Champions yo no creo que
va a ser posible y cuál es su conclusión
Donald Trump tiene mucho talento y con
debido respeto a yopaiden al presente de
los Estados Unidos creo que Trump sigue
siendo político más interesante e
importante probablemente de los Estados
Unidos
de ahora al 2024 Y definitivamente sus
decisiones van a determinar el rumbo del
partido republicano y definitivamente el
éxito o no del partido en las elecciones
de 2024 y también definirá mucho la
historia política de Estados Unidos
porque sin duda alguna hay un capítulo
que comenzó con Donald Trump en la
presidencia y ese capítulo lo seguimos
viviendo hasta el día de hoy John Iván
les agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros haber hecho este análisis para
la audiencia de France 24 en
Latinoamérica ya veremos En qué termina
toda esta historia apenas fue un anuncio
de una aspiración para una candidatura
nos queda mucho camino por delante ya
veremos qué sucede en qué termina esta
historia es todo por el momento En
nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos la sintonía de la producción
del estuvo a cargo de Giovanni agudelo y
la producción de invitados estuvo a
cargo de Tania Herrera sigan con
nosotros
[Música]